[Musik]
herrlich einfach nur herrlich steil oder
scale hat uns nach dem einfluss von
musik auf verschiedene
alltagssituationen gefragt und dann
musste ich als erstes an traurige musik
denken ich höre ganz gerne traurige
musik selbst wenn ich gut drauf bin und
obwohl ich mich als ziemlich fröhlichen
menschen bezeichnen würde
für mich persönlich gibt es außerdem
nichts besseres für ein gebrochenes herz
als ich in trauriger musik zu suhlen wie
ein schweinchen im schlaf
[Musik]
wie kann es sein dass man etwas genießt
das ein traurig macht eine neue studie
hat nicht nur herausgefunden dass
menschen traurige musik unterschiedlich
stark genießen sondern auch dass
diejenigen die sich bei dem höheren
traurige klänge er berührt und bewegt
statt einfach nur miserabel fühlen
besonders empathische menschen sind
empathie also die fähigkeit sich in
andere hineinzuversetzen und mitzufühlen
ruft beim hören trauriger musik also
auch positive emotionen hervor musik
bestimmt unsere stimmung generell sehr
stark weswegen sich tatsächlich viele
forscher mit dem einfluss von musik auf
unseren alltag beschäftigen zum beispiel
haben forscher herausgefunden dass
extrem und laute musik wie zum beispiel
metal aggressionen nicht fördert sondern
ebenso vermehrt positive emotionen
hervorruft extrem und laute musik
scheint also eher eine
aggressionsbewältigung zu sein anstatt
aggression zu verstärken passend dazu
hat uns dem bfd bzw
die beats gefragt ob mettler ältere
menschen sind tatsächlich haben sich
wissenschaftler an geschaut inwieweit
der musikgeschmack eines menschen dessen
charakter voraussagen kann
dazu haben wir euch in der infobox eine
interessante infografik verlinkt aber
disclaimer die wissenschaftler sagen
selbst dass diese studie mit vorsicht zu
genießen ist natürlich kann ein
musikgeschmack nicht umfassen den
charakter eines menschen beschreiben
aber der musikgeschmack kann ganz gut
voraussagen ob ein mensch er intro oder
extrovertiert ist hörer sollen besonders
extrovertiert und selbstbewusstsein
metal hingegen eher introvertiert
kreativ und entspannt aber zurück zur
musik in verschiedenen
alltagssituationen beim sport hätte ich
jetzt gedacht das motivierende schnelle
up musik hilfreich ist aber hier am
forscher beobachtet dass jede art von
musik auch fleißige musik zu erhöhten
sportliche ausdauerleistungen führt
beim arbeiten vor allem beim kreativen
arbeiten soll musik innovations- fördert
sein vorausgesetzt die musik nicht zu
laos 70 dezibel das soll laut einer
studie optimal sein das ist immerhin so
laut wie ein havel wenn ihr also
kreative ideen braucht dann versucht es
doch mal mit mittel lauter instrumenten
sehen
[Musik]